I have a very clear memory of this uh
album coming out because I had there's I
think a three-day difference between
When In Utero drops and when I start my
late night television show oh wow uh and
I remembered the music on the uh album
because I was such a huge fan being such
a fat background music to the terror and
the weirdness of me starting a late
night show from complete obscurity in in
uh in 1993 so that's similar to the
Nirvana experience I would imagine that
you know at the time we were when the
band became
popular um in 1991 we were so young yeah
I think I was 21 or 22 and you might
have been 25 or something but we were we
were um we were kids and so you know
when you talk about the the amount of
time um that that's gone by it's to me
it's not even so much about the um the
years it's about the experiences um that
just kind of LED one after another going
from from three kids that were basically
living or touring out of a van to then
becoming a huge band and um and then in
Udo becoming uh the sort of the
uncomfortable soundtrack back to that
sort of um transition I think like
that was by 1992
1993 um we were living in a different
world than we were just 16 months before
you know I was thinking about it today
and I was thinking the only way that you
can understand the making of inudo is to
understand where you were at that time
the only way to understand that is to
start
with the never mind which had it's Gein
recer records modest Expectations by the
record label they I think they were
going to be very happy if you sold
250,000 units they printed 50,000 units
of the CDs 50,000 50,000 thinking that
should do it and if we have to make more
we will I talked to someone who was
working at geffin at the time they said
when never mind
hit uh and started to blow up and then
really blow up at one point they had to
stop making and Manufacturing all of the
other CDs for the other artists on their
label and turn them all over to making
never mind which sounds like something
that just doesn't happen it was
completely
unprecedented and so that's the good
news but with that comes all kinds of
well you you mentioned time
Conan and so like personally that you
know that was 30 years ago but that time
from when Never Mind released and then
Kurt
died what happened in that span of time
feels like it was 10 years it was so
much going there was so much intense
yeah I was just thinking like you know
for me it took my entire childhood to
prepare me for adolescence right and
then it took my entire adolescence and
young adulthood to prepare me for being
gainfully employed and independent as a
as a person right so like you have a
long runway for like the major stages in
in your life and like Nirvana went from
being couch Surfers to being the biggest
band ever in the world in a span of
about 18 months you guys are responsible
for an industry
and the thing that occurs to me is that
Fame money success is great news for a
lot of artists in the business a lot of
music artists if you come from the punk
world and you are religious adherence to
the punk ethos which you guys were and
Kurt
was success is tricky
because when you there's so many artists
if they make a lot of money go out get a
Bentley you know Jesus the The Beatles
were very comfortable going out and
getting a Rolls-Royce and pay either
that or pay 90% taxes right right okay
well that's a good point I hadn't
thought of that and we're going to do a
second one we get into
taxation but what I wanted to point out
was there's a whole culture of yay we
made it and we throw money
around there's almost a shame and a trap
that's set if you're part of the punk
ethos isn't there so I want this is
something that I have run into over and
over and over again is people outside
the music seen people who are not band
members not musicians not part of the
culture of punk at all ascribing to
punks this notion that success is bad
and this notion that if you are
successful you are somehow bad and evil
and that it is that we don't want people
to become successful I have never
experienced that genuinely from anybody
in any anyone in in the punk scene that
wasn't purely a jealousy
an expression of jealousy right on the
whole Nirvana's fans wanted Nirvana to
become successful and S self- sustaining
and be loved there's a kind of an an a
sniping that is ascribed to people in
the music scene that didn't exist it's a
critical creation when what actually
happened was a lot of people in an
aspirational way grasping for Success
did all kinds of grotesque horish things
things to try to secure success for
themselves material success or artistic
success or whatever and that was reacted
negatively toward by everybody who was
you know sincere about what they were
doing so I just wanted to clear the air
and say like like there was no animosity
toward Nirvana Nirvana anos I'm talking
about the band itself I'm talking about
well you know I'm talking about Kurt or
maybe you guys feeling you've got
there's a I'm talking about two feelings
immense Pride that you're the number one
band in the world yeah and maybe a
little bit of Jesus well what the I
think what okay so
um you know before before we made the
record never
mind
um we were pretty much living in squalor
right so I was living with Kurt in this
tiny little apartment and there were
just corn do sticks and cigarettes all
over the place and it was like pretty
disgusting yeah um I would have
done anything to had to have my own
apartment you know like and and to be
able to do that through making music for
to
actually it it also the I know that the
the transition happened really quickly
but it didn't happen you didn't just
wind up with a million dollars in your
mailbox the next day it went from being
like uh the prium went up to $15 a day I
was like oh my God that means I can get
two packs of cigarettes or whatever and
then you know when from this could
possibly get better like I'm
I honestly that way oh my gosh we're
staying in a motel you know I'm sharing
a room with Kurt or whatever but it's
not someone's floor and then just small
things and then um from September to
December is of 1991 is when everything
really blew up and um I I didn't I
really didn't feel any I didn't feel
conflicted or any guilt or shame in
knowing like oh I just I just paid off
my mother's house yeah or I I bought my
mother a car or um now I can afford to
you know buy a new pair of shoes or
whatever it was I didn't and I think the
reason why I I I personally didn't feel
so conflicted about everything was
because I knew that the band
um
uh hadn't done anything
outside of our our our true selves to to
get there we just did the thing that we
did and then it happened and so
um that was just my experience
after and then I and then I got to I got
to move in with another friend and have
a house and I remember it's funny you
talk about the Bentley remember that
weird Yugoslavian car that you
bought did you own a Yugo no no what was
it didn't you get some car didn't you
buy some car that was like this tiny
thing oh the Renault dine somebody gave
it to me right wait that's that was your
rockar moment is that someone gave you a
Rena doline which sounds like like a
shoe more than a car I barely fit in it
I got it running pretty good but yeah I
mean of course we didn't go straight to
the Bentley and stuff like that but I
mean it I I I was very happy to um have
finally been able to really support
myself as a
musician